the US economy is going to melt down in
2024 if you're an employee it's going to
be
disaster between technology changing
wiping out
jobs more performance-based
pay things are just changing
dramatically now take the other side the
entrepreneur side guess what it doesn't
matter the educational system is like an
employee Farm we grow employees in the
educational system that'll fit into
somebody else's entrepreneurial dream if
if you're an entrepreneur and you're not
building your brand you can divide what
your expected income should be by
five so how can we survive and thrive
during the coming economic crisis as
entrepreneurs as content creators and as
business Builders what are the habits
the mindsets necessary for winning in
every environment and what are the
specific business and branding advice
tips from a millionaire that we can all
apply whether we're just starting or
wanting to grow well in this episode of
the think media podcast I am joined by
the legendary Eric warry in fact I asked
chat gbt to write an introduction about
him and I'll read it word for word and
it says this today we are honored to
host a legend in the world of network
marketing he's inspired Millions with
his game-changing strategies coached
countless individuals on their journey
to entrepreneurial success and penned
the bestseller GoPro Deep dive with us
into the insights and wisdom of the in
comparable Eric warry wow chat GPT is
pretty good it's pretty good and welcome
to the show Eric thanks so much for
being here it's my pleasure my pleasure
I'm glad to do it so I'm fired up to
really go through layers of content
towards the second half of the show
we'll be talking about should Network
marketers use YouTube and video and
maybe how could those listening to this
that are looking for a better way of
monetizing they could maybe tap into
that opportunity but I want to start
with the economy and there's actually
one of my favorite creators called clear
value tax he made a video um summarizing
a lot of data the US economy is going to
melt down in 2024 so right now
economists are divided about 50% believe
that in the next 12 months there's going
to be a recession 50% believe it'll be
avoided polls indicate that 69% of us
consumers expect a recession in 12
months and 84% of CEOs believe that's
going to happen and some people think
there's positive indicators because GDP
is growing but when you look at Rising
interest rates really estate market when
you look at the long pause the Federal
Reserve is going to do maybe raise and
student loan payments that just kicked
in as well as the dollar not going as
far the economy is a major question mark
and you've been in the game a long time
I value your perspective I'm just
curious what's your mindset how are you
approaching this what are maybe some of
your predictions maybe regardless of
what happens what are you personally
doing in response to the environment
we're going into well it's interesting
question and it is because it matters
are you an employee or are you an
entrepreneur so which assumption would
you like me to take well I'd like you to
maybe hit both of them because yeah tell
us the two scenarios if you're an
employee it's going to be
disaster between technology uh changing
wiping out jobs uh more
performance-based pay not wages anymore
more and more companies are going to pay
only for performance not just
salespeople but everybody you're not
going to be able to hide inside of
corporate structures there's all kinds
of things happening inside of commercial
real estate everything else all across
that landscape things are just changing
dramatically one of the things the
pandemic did is it is it shrunk maybe a
10-year transition window into three
years our habits have changed you take a
look at what happened to movie theaters
as an example it used to be a regular
normal thing now when was the last time
you went to a movie theater to actually
see a movie it's got to be something
special and there isn't that much
special that your big screen TV or maybe
you upgraded that TV during the pandemic
to be able to watch is not a a close um
comparable to that experience so you go
to an AMC theater right now and it's
kind of sad you know it's like they're
trying to please come back it's it's
over it's over people have changed now
they're they're watching things on their
tablets and on their on their laptops
and their desktops and screencasting
from their phone up to a screen on their
wall uh I have a huge screen TV at my
house we don't want to go to the movie
theater we're fine uh where we are so
just hurry up and and release that movie
and put it on Amazon Prime or wherever I
can watch it and that's where I'm going
to watch it so same thing's going to
happen across all employee sectors in my
opinion it's going to get squeezed
downsizing uh unemployment is going to
go up lots of challenges now take the
other side the entrepreneur side guess
what it doesn't
matter economic boom or Bust it doesn't
matter it never has for an
entrepreneur you people every election
cycle people like this one this one if
the other guy gets in it's the end of
the world for sure that's that's been
said every election for my entire
lifetime and for for some employees
maybe that's true but for entrepreneurs
it never is because entrepreneurs adapt
and entrepreneurs look at every
obstacles and opportunity and
entrepreneurs
actually in the face of recession that's
where most success stories are created
is entrepreneurs step in during those
periods of time go back and and reverse
engineer all the big companies that you
can think of and find out when they
started you're going to find them
starting in pretty difficult times so
entrepreneurs look for opportunity when
other people are frozen in fear they
adapt and they pivot while other people
are slow to change
I'll tell you this I think the next 18
months to 3 years is going to be A Tale
of Two Cities literally uh for some it's
going to be the best of times they're
going to find opportunity pivot adapt
adjust innovate and for some it's going
to be the worst of times it's going to
be disaster and they're going to have
lots of stuff that they can blame it on
they're going to blame it on whoever got
in the White House they're going to
blame it on global economics they blame
it on the FED uh blame it on interest
rates blame it on debt they blame it on
a million things but entrepreneurs just
say that's fine you guys stay over there
all confused and blaming each other I'm
going to go innovate over here and I'll
create a Better Business out of it you
know so i' I've always kind of grinned
at the you know what are you g to do I'm
going to adapt that's what I'm going to
do you know if the Republicans get in
I'll adapt if Democrats get in it's not
the end of the world I'll adapt and
that's what I've been doing my whole
life there's probably two types of
people listening to this uh one group
got super fired up they already have the
entrepreneur mentality they maybe were
looking ahead with some trepidation but
you just let that fire again it's like
that's right it's A Tale of Two Cities
and I know which Camp I'm going to be in
there's others though that you know we
speak to YouTube creators content
creators people stepping in the creater
economy business owners that are trying
to get more leads and clients and sales
with content and then maybe a third
group of those that are looking for a
side hustle those that are full-time
right now you're like employees are
going to get squeezed you got to be
thinking about creating extra streams of
Revenue what do you think it takes to
make that transition maybe be clearer
there are those who say okay well it's
going to be good for entrepreneurs but
I'm not an entrepreneur is there an
opportunity for anybody to become one
sure but it takes a bit of of
reprogramming your
mind one of my mentors his name is Sam
georgees he um was Tony Robins CEO for
22 years incredible guy retired lives
here in Las
Vegas he says there's two kinds of
people one or coin operated and the
other ones are entrepreneurs and coin
operated you know put in put in a coin
you'll get a result you know and they're
they're they're exchanging their time
for money or or an effort or a result
for money and entrepreneurs are willing
to take bigger risk and and do what they
need to do so most people have been
trained to think like an employee since
they were two years old do as you're
told or there's going to be consequences
brush your teeth there's going to be
consequences stop hitting your sister
you know finish your vegetables go to
bed or there's going to be consequences
and then it repeats in school you know
study for the test that there's going to
be consequences you don't pass this
grade there's going to be consequences
that gets built in Don't Be Tardy too
many days or there's going to be
consequences you get detention whatever
you get written up in your permanent
record which I've never seen by the way
they threatened it so many times when I
went to school and then when you get out
of school you get a job and in that job
you are consequence driven as well show
up on time and there's consequences
here's all long lunches there's
consequences you know make sure you
perform good enough or you know there's
going to be consequences there could be
rewards too uh so we've been trained to
think like employees and it's exactly
opposite of how entrepreneurs think so
employees when I when I speak around the
world and I ask people what comes to
mind when I say the word
work and guess what I get pain
obligation traffic drug
rudery um uncomfortable
obligation that's the list yeah and
because of that and because they've been
trained as an employee to
work so so they can rest the rest is the
objective the retirement is the
objective the weekend is the objective
right to get away from all this stuff is
the objective so entrepreneurs
look at work completely
different work is Passion work is
creation work is purpose work is Mission
um work is
contribution you know so why would you
want to get away from that y so the
employee minded people think the
entrepreneurs are crazy people because
they rest just long enough to work while
the employees are working just long
enough to
rest so most entrepreneurs don't can't
even fathom I can't even fathom
retirement sure I can I can fathom
lifestyle doing it my way but I can't
fathom like wanting to get away from
this so that's just one example there's
a million that I could give you
entrepreneurs think on one side of the
coin and employees think on the other
side of the coin so whether it's work or
investment or sacrifice or time you know
uh an employee for example is willing to
give you about two weeks and if if
within two weeks you don't get paid
they're gone yeah but an entrepreneur is
willing to be underpaid for a long
period of time yes fairly paid for a
very short period of time and then
overpaid for a long period of time
they're willing to trade under for over
and that's different right um than what
people that this is unfair you're taking
advantage of me I'm putting in all this
work I'm not getting any results or
you're working for yourself you know
this is stupid why am I doing this I'm
getting paid $1 an hour for the amount
of time that I'm putting into growing my
YouTube channel or or growing my
business this is dumb this is this
doesn't even make any sense but you got
to put in that price and you're willing
to invest your time where employees are
like nope if I don't get a a certain
amount per hour y not doing it you know
same thing with the support
entrepreneurs create support everybody
else is looking for support you know
they create their own support and I
could go on and on and on but you really
have to learn how to think like an
entrepreneur and you can reprogram your
mind cuz I think we were all born with
creation and contribution and Mission
and passion and all of that stuff in us
and it was beaten into US programmed
into us to do as we're told or there's
going to be consequences that's the
difference were you born into an
entrepreneur family a little I was born
a little bit into an entrepreneurial
family I I well that's not true I I I
would
say Scrappy yeah Scrappy figure it out
out type of a family what did your
parents do my when I was growing up my
dad sold
Insurance um you know Mom took care of
the house insurance has some scale
Dynamics to it a little bit Yeah sold
some insurance we lived in Detroit and
then my dad became a Christian he became
he decided my uncle was had started a
church in Minnesota so my dad packed up
the family quit
Insurance in his early 30s drove us all
over to Minnesota to start like a church
camp
for the big church so Scrappy figuring
it out never had any money budget
whatever didn't matter was able to kind
of put put a little church camp together
Salvation Army uh runs that church camp
today yeah but uh and my dad never took
a salary from the church he worked for
the church but he never took a salary
and he always just bought and sold cars
and you know with scrappy little ways to
to make money make enough to make ends
meet you know so we were always we never
went hungry but we never really kind of
had the cool stuff so growing up I
wanted to have the cool stuff you know
so then how did you reprogram your mind
it took a bit
um I I had some I look at my mind is a
computer and I had some mental viruses
in my
mind um three of them in particular one
I was a professional blamer nothing was
ever my fault and I was good I could
convince the teacher that the dog ate
the homework I could figure out a way
that it was never my fault uh I could I
could move blame around and that was
okay you know you kind of get out of
doing extra work or doing things or
whatever when you're growing up versus
taking responsibility right I almost
never took responsibility directly I was
a blamer second is I wanted people to
pay me more first and then I'd work
harder give me a little bit more money
and I'll work harder I worked one of my
first jobs is I I used to I worked at
this little boat
dock um company that rented fishing
boats to people in in the lakes in
Minnesota and I was making this certain
amount of money and this guy who is like
two years older than me was making you
know almost double the amount of money
not a lot but yeah double the amount and
I said I I asked the boss one day I said
H how can I make that kind of money and
he said well which is a good question by
by the way if you work for somebody how
can I how what would need to happen he
said well you you know he's been here
for a while and he does this and this
and this and this and this and this and
this are you I said are you telling me
that if I do those things that I can
make that money he said yeah absolutely
so okay next day I mean I'm there early
I'm picking up gum wrappers out of the
parking lot I'm I I ran everybody was
shocked everybody was watching me around
and like what happened to this kid you
know I'm getting these looks like from
employees you're making us look bad and
from the boss he's like you know I'm
getting these approval nods from the
boss and I killed it that day I mean the
the docks Were Gleaming and the boats
were shiny and it was because of me so
at the end of the day I'm so proud I go
to the boss I said well did it I'm ready
I'm ready and he said Son look it was a
good day and we were all impressed but
it was just one day you got to show me
that you can do that day in and day out
because this is first time I've ever
seen it m and I went huh he's just going
to try and take advantage of
me so no if if you if you give me the
raise you could see what I'll do but
since you're not going to then I'm going
to work up to that level and I'm going
to and that's all you're going to get
then you lowered your performance which
is visibly like intentionally lowered
yeah you know I'm I'm only going to do
what you pay me for it's kind of a you
know I don't want to make anybody mad
but kind of a union mentality sure you
know within the policies procedures kind
of
thing so I went back you know and I
repeated that in every job mhm I had 18
jobs by the time I was 23 for real wow
so so it's hard to do you think about
that you get a job you know go to work
get fired you know or quit uh and do
that 18 times so that was my second big
virus it was pay me first and then I'll
work harder and the third thing was I'm
not sure where this came from but I'd
rather get away with something and than
earn it
I'd rather talk my way into a situation
I'd rather sneak into the drive-in movie
than than pay for a ticket I'd rather if
you found something mislabeled at a at a
store and you could get it for a better
price it was so exciting you know I'd
rather find a little corner to cut sure
instead of just earn it right so I get
involved early in my early 20s in direct
sales network marketing and for the
first time all three of those things are
punished three of those viruses in my
mind were punished like smashed because
I could blame anybody but it wasn't
going to change my check yep I had to
take
responsibility um my check was an exact
reflection of the value that I was
bringing in to the penny you know so I
couldn't ask for more money unless I was
providing more production it's purely
performance-based yeah um and third I
learned that getting away with something
trying to get lucky be in the right
place at the right time you got to
always be in the right place the right
time it's so much easier to just be
excellent so I would say it probably
took me 3 years after I was
22 before I was able to rewire my brain
and go this is not serving me I need to
go over here and you know a lot of plan
du review a lot of trial and error to
get there how much how important has
books learning studying events investing
in yourself been for you since 22 you
know when I finished High School um I
applied to the colleges that my friends
applied to and I got rejected from all
of them because I have a 1.8 GPA in high
school I went to one trimester of
Community College Normandale Community
College um mostly to play football got
myself just destroyed uh playing
football and um so I leave formal
education say you know what I I don't
need need read another book the rest of
my life you know I again growing up in
the church Church I'd read a page of the
Bible and it put me out I would just
knock me to sleep so fast
so what got me connected to personal
development and growth and books and
learning was the network marketing space
I I got handed a copy of a
bootlegged audio cassette from Jim ran
which was called the seed in the SE and
somebody had just recorded it in the
audience and made an audio tape of it
and it was from a shackley convention
and I listen to that I'm like oh my gosh
this is so good this he's talking about
me and I'm like I got this Vision that I
could maybe make something of my life
and and what I found it in the
profession of network marketing
specifically you can take one idea and
make money the next day one tiny little
thing you take that into the post office
and take that idea you're not going to
make money the next day you're you're in
a structure yeah the structure of your
job is limiting you cuz you are just
painting by numbers there but you have
total creativity
and so in that in that talk he said for
things to
change I had to change for things to get
better I had to get better and that
that's what his mentor told him and I'm
like huh number one that makes sense for
me I've got to change but number two
when I'm talking to prospects I'm going
to use that so the next day literally
the next day somebody says you know I'm
not sure you know I got to you know this
might not be a good time for me and I
said you know look let me tell you what
one of my mentors told
me he told me just yesterday for things
to change you got to change and for
things to get better you got to get
better he said you know what you're
right let's do this and he signs up and
I'm like this is like a magic trick I
got to find some more of these phrases
yeah um and and in his talks you know
then I bought everything Jim Ron had um
in his talks he said start reading
leaders are readers start reading 10
pages of a good book a day he gave a few
recommendations
but and I did I you know and I I kind of
went back and forth between fiction and
non-fiction because I you get a little
over overdone with non-fiction sometimes
so I need some stories I need some drama
I need to figure out some people so I
started reading 10 pages and I developed
that new muscle and I know today
everybody's like no I like audiobooks I
like there's a different part of your
brain yeah that that engages with that
and I became hungry in in growing myself
and improving myself me being the asset
as an entrepreneur and that's what most
entrepreneurs don't realize it's not
your product it's not your platform it's
you if you grow you a little bit at a
time
compounded and and learn how to I I
would say you know books audio those
were the start for me and then events
seminars but the absolute cheat code to
accelerate your growth coaches mentors
masterminds that's literally like a time
machine yes you step into that that
environment and you come out three years
smarter without being three years older
it's a it's it's the most amazing thing
and if if people did not hear anything
find a coach find somebody who has the
knowledge that you have and you don't
have to go through their pain in order
to be able to get it give them the
dollars save the time we only have so
much time so that was the big
breakthrough coaches mentors and
masterminds that some of that was built
into the network marketing Community
others I found um but but um huge huge
break through for me I and I will tell
you I think I've read more than anybody
I know since then you know a a lot a lot
of books so going into 2024 in light of
whatever's on the horizon for someone
who's either just starting on their
Journey maybe more mid on on their
Journey or even more advanced but they
are committed to lifelong learning what
are some Classics and maybe some current
books that you think would be good for
reprogramming your mind to absolutely be
a part of the city that wins of the
group of people that adapts and
innovates and is creative in these uh
next 12 to 24 months I would say it kind
of doesn't matter where you start it
just matters that you start M find find
something that that is for you you know
you read outliers from Malcolm Gladwell
and you know the only thing anybody
remembers from that book is 10,000 hours
right you know but that's enough sure
that's enough I I it's worth the 20
bucks yeah for 10,000 I have to do
10,000 hours of something before I
consider myself being any good I watched
uh an interview with Jimmy Donaldson Mr
Beast a couple days ago and he was just
saying go make a 100 videos yeah and
after you make a 100 videos then let's
look back and figure out how we're going
to do do something better y it's same
kind of principle right y so you're
going to find good ideas all over the
place find the most recommended
entrepreneurial books on Amazon it's
different personalities for different
people you can go find Atomic habits
over here you can go find strengths
finders 2.0 over there if you want to
become a better leader you know find a
great leadership book over here if you
got to get your mindset right grab
something from goggin or grab something
from ran or whatever
find something that that my my biggest
encouragement is just find something
that resonates with you lean in and then
you can challenge your mind to expand
beyond what you already agree with yeah
and find new things that'll challenge
you to be able to kind of uh explore
other parts of your personality or weak
spots in your business like strength
finders as an example have you ever read
strength finders 2.0 I've taken the test
I've never read the book it's on my
shelf it's so good um and the test lets
you know where your strengths are and
the thesis of the book is successful
people lean into their strengths and
they manage their weaknesses and
everybody else tries to strengthen all
of their weaknesses right let go of that
yeah let somebody else do that stuff yes
just lean in uh to the strength piece
and that idea is so big because it just
was as soon as I got that I'm like huh I
can do the stuff that I enjoy doing even
though a lot of it's hard work and I can
manage help have somebody else help me
with the rest
I'm in so the personal development Gres
are always good you know find who
resonates with you find something and
once you find one it'll lead you to the
next it'll recommend the next it'll lead
you to the next you you'll talk with
people about the book that you read and
they'll give you some suggestions and
it'll go from there so and we got to get
to content in like the part three and uh
we'll talk about that I actually do want
to talk a little bit about your book
because you're a massively best-selling
author with your book go embarassed I I
have one book that sold 5 million copies
and I I I have six books in my head and
I'm such a procrastinator I got so much
going on that I I have not taken the
time to get the other six out of my head
I like to say I'm a an author yes but
I'm not a writer did you find that for
people listening to this that getting
what you know into a book do you believe
that's still powerful today 100% what
what are the results of I mean it's wild
too 5 million copies is crazy but your
your book GoPro seven steps to becoming
a network marketing professional what
did that do for you it well first of all
when you
self-publish uh and you make five bucks
a book you make a lot more than instead
of 50 cents yeah yeah second you don't
need Publishers today you can go direct
to your consumer if you build your
audience right provide value to your
community know who you're writing for
what what you're doing with it but it
did so much I can't
even my speaking fees went through the
roof because people wanted to bring the
guy who wrote
GoPro everybody in my particular
profession knows the book has bought the
book there's probably 20 million copies
that have been ripped off in every
language around the world fine whatever
yeah the reputation the brand uh
opportunities the conversations it could
open up up pretty much any door uh it it
came kind of this little calling card
like rich Rich Dad Poor Dad was for
Robert kosaki or or uh the 22 immutable
laws of leadership for John Maxwell um
those types of things yes that's what it
it it became kind of a centerpiece and
you'll find because it was called GoPro
a lot of our stuff is kind of GoPro this
and GoPro that and GoPro the other thing
um like we have a GoPro experience event
that we do once a year a big event um uh
that we broadcast around the world so I
I was
fooled by a
billionaire the billi millionaire
said don't ever put your knowledge in a
book and sell it for $20 when you can
put it in a course and sell it for a
th don't ever do it it's the biggest
mistake and I believed him W for 15
years and I've I I went you know what I
might be wrong and if I'm wrong I'm
going I'm I'm I'll I'll be happy to
admit it but I'm doing it because it's I
have to get it out I have to write this
down there's there's a need for it so I
wrote it and I was like man he was so
wrong he was so wrong uh the
opportunities and doors and you there's
always room for you can give everything
away in a book and then still have a
course you know you can still have an
event totally you know you can still
improve and enhance on that um but he
was he was very very wrong sure yeah
that's a I think people are constantly
asking what do I give away free what do
I sell if I put it all in a book I think
I heard Russell Brunson talk about that
that like everything that's in traffic
Secrets or expert Secrets would also
then be in a course but the course is a
different format video teaching and then
it would also be in like a 2day event
but that's also a different format
experience and then it' also be in The
Mastermind but you don't have the
personalization where the person knows
you and everybody else there so I think
people are afraid right of giving away
too much when actually you know it's
biblical like give and you shall receive
pressed down you know flowing over in
abundance like more than you could ever
imagine and uh that's that is
interesting that kind of leads to
building a personal brand and I want to
talk about your content strategy and I
we'll talk about how network marketing
can apply to all this and how Network
marketers could do all the above but if
we go really macro this idea of personal
branding when did that term hit your
radar were you doing it on accident
before it became a pop culture term in
entrepreneurship or have you been
intentionally trying to build your
personal brand for how long it's
interesting how it all came about
because we we when you're successful in
the network marketing space which I was
in the field growing large teams I had
half a million people on my team 63 63
countries around the world so you're
kind of a little bit branded in that
experience you know how you show up and
you know your presence Your Leader your
team identity and your culture and all
that becomes a bit branded but not
necessarily to the world or to other
companies within your space so
2008 I'm I'm uh checking out social
media and Facebook has come out it's
it's really they it was for college
students to start and they're starting
to expand it to like high school
students and stuff and I'm hearing about
this and I'm going hm this looks like
something because this is back in the
times of
Myspace and people had their you know
their theme song on their Myspace
Channel and stuff um so I ask around who
who who knows somebody that really knows
this you know online space names popping
up all over the place and one consistent
theme was Gary vaynerchuk so like oh
okay I check this guy out and he's doing
this really low quality uh wine tasting
this young kid from New Jersey sitting
in his dad's wine store tasting wine
talking about the New York Jets and
ranting occasionally about stuff you
know being nice to people whatever and
I'm like and he he was getting 880,000
views he was getting written up in major
papers he was on Jimmy Kimmel or
something what I'm like what is going on
so I called him up I said you know two
hours of your time can come out and and
and I want to pick your brains so I paid
him 10 grand back in 2008 for two hours
you know which would be a bargain today
um sat down with him and said just
reverse engineer everything you're doing
with wine I want to do it with network
marketing idea in my mind Jim ran was
just at the last days of his life and it
was a hero for me if he had a little
camera in his pocket and instead of just
audio there was all of this evidence of
his life he documented it it would be a
cool gift to give the world and he
couldn't do it and I was never going to
be Jim ran but I could start I could try
so you know I sat down with Gary and we
went through all the stuff and basically
all the stuff he put in crush it um that
first book that he came out with and I
went home it was February 2009 and my
birthday was in March March 11th of 2009
I said I'm just going to start I have no
idea what I'm doing I have no clue I
bought a bunch of camera equipment I
never used uh a bunch of lights that
overheated my house that I never used uh
I had Final Cut Express that somebody
created a little template for me that I
could record the video put it in the
middle and squeeze it together and
Export it and post it to a Blog and I
just started I just said I'm going to do
kind of midform stuff once a day every
day uh not necessarily every day but
about 250 times first year with No
Agenda nothing to nothing to buy nothing
to join it was just here's ideas here's
things I've learned uh here's tips
here's strategies occasional interview a
guy um and throw that up there in
segments and I would like send a little
email blast out to whoever had an email
uh list of at a little group on Facebook
which was capped at 5,000 and my kids a
fit by the way because they're like oh
this is for kids this is not for adults
you're going to be a creepy old guy uh
on Facebook you get off of here so uh
but I did anyway they blocked me for a
minute but then they unblocked me funny
so I i' learned this little process I
had all my little cheat sheets had no
ability to do that but I can share an
idea so I started March of 2000 March 11
2009 um and found my tribe found my
following found my voice
and kept sharing and from that maybe
like the next year people are like
please do you have any kind of product
anything and I made a CD set an audio CD
Set uh what from a live event that I did
with a couple hundred people in the room
eight hours of content sold that sold
like crazy I'm like huh so then I did an
event and you were shipping it yeah
shipping CDs I you believe it so then I
did an event called GoPro GoPro
recruiting mastery we called it at the
Monte Carlo here in Las Vegas 200 people
at the event three days brought in my
personal development friends and um and
that went from 200 to 400 to 800 to 2400
to I mean the biggest one we did was
68,000 yeah 68,000 people in an event
paid event um so in that period of time
and probably four years in that's when I
wrote GoPro the book that put everything
on turbo fuel and I've had to Pivot A
Million Way a million times along the
way but I never really thought of myself
as a brand I thought of myself more of a
as a teacher as a as a friend to this
particular tribe entrepreneurs you know
it's kind of a lonely Journey here some
ideas on how you can go do better y um
and and uh and it turned into a big
thing for me and now today lately we've
been connecting you've been doubling
Down On Media do you feel like you there
was a time when you got too busy where
maybe you weren't as intense as you are
now and what would you say on a scale
from 1 to 10 how seriously you're taking
media at Large YouTube You're Going all
in on YouTube video podcasting but on a
scale from 1 to 10 how intense are you
going now did that number change and why
did it change well I'll I'll give you
something that I recently come to
believe if you think you're a big deal
you're comparing yourself to the wrong
people you need you know so long as
you're the big you know I'm doing more
than every everybody else is doing so I
was comparing myself to people who
weren't doing anything on social sure
you know I was crushing them you know
they made five videos and quit I made
250 videos a year I'm I'm a I'm a killer
yeah but I made so many mistakes mistake
number one Gary recommended I put all my
videos on vidler yeah instead of YouTube
for like three years that was the hugest
mistake ever yeah um second I thought I
was a big shot doing that stuff doing it
all myself
uh for like five six years I did every
piece of it myself shot recorded edited
you know put it out there almost never
edited much but I just go to camera and
here's the idea for today here's a
recommended book and I'll see you
tomorrow and I'd shoot it out um but
looking
back I'm so
embarrassed that I didn't just suck all
the oxygen out of the space MH I I
should have a YouTube channel 20 times
its size right now yeah it's 400,000
subscri subcribers right now and it's
ridiculously embarrassingly terrible um
so a few people made made me mad Alex
hor mosy made me mad Grant Cardone made
me mad uh Patrick B David made me mad
you know all these guys are friends and
I'm like I I'm counting the quantity
that they're putting out yeah while
running big businesses and I'm running a
big business I have all my limiting
beliefs yeah and I'm counting the
quality quantity that I'm putting out
I'm putting out you know whatever 25
pieces
on Instagram per month or whatever and I
said uh enough so ramped up I mean I'm
talking the last four months three
months even yeah um re-engage the
podcast I was getting like 50 to 80,000
downloads a week when I stopped doing it
because I just wasn't really aiming at
it stuff yeah and you can have a little
bit of challenge when you have a lot of
financial
success you know where you lose the
grittiness of it you know cuz we
achieved all our financial goals we had
you know lifestyles of rich and famous
crazy stuff so I lost a little of the
grittiness and I was comparing myself to
the wrong people so when I found some
people who were doing things at scale
the way and and I saw the results of
that that they were getting I went hm
okay I have to have better systems I
have to have better team I have to have
different vision and I have to do scale
what I realized is quantity is the
solution to just about every problem you
just have to really ramp up quantity to
get the feedback loop so you can improve
the quality right hey we're about to get
back into the podcast in just a second
but I have a question for you do you
want to grow your personal brand this
year do you need more leads and sales in
your business if the answer is yes then
right now is the best time to go all in
on YouTube Today's podcast is brought to
you by think masterclass.com where you
can get on demand access to a 1hour deep
dive training revealing how to start and
grow a profitable YouTube channel this
year for a limited time you can get
access to this on demand class entirely
for free where you will learn the three
biggest mistakes that people make when
starting a YouTube channel the new rules
and changes that have been happening on
YouTube and how you can use them to
create an unfair advantage and the exact
strategy we use at think media to
generate over
350,000 organic views every single day
the data is clear 70% of viewers claim
that YouTube makes them more aware of
new brands so don't wait any longer to
start growing your brand and business
with YouTube just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to this
nolu highly tactical free onDemand
training that's think masterclass.com so
now it's 300 pieces of content a month
on Instagram it's uh you know know in
total probably seven or 800 pieces
across platforms uh different types of
content podcasts up one once a week you
were a guest um I have enough recorded
to get me for like the next four months
so I'm pushing the team to get to two
week and they're freaking out on me
because of the number of clips that have
to be pulled out of that in order to be
able to do it right yeah um so i' be
like come on we got to get better
systems we got to go cuz I got a pretty
reasonable team now help helping with
all that so podcast is growing we're top
20 uh 25 top 30 in in business category
so which I'm happy about that on um on
Apple and we're working on the Spotify
side I just decided enough I'm going to
go big so I've heard Simon synk call use
the term worthy
Rivals I've heard you know everyone
knows the quote comparison is the thief
of Joy however for the entrepreneur you
said you were comparing yourself to the
wrong people yeah comparison's also an
opportunity to be challenged to get
better I mean some people get really
demoralized when they compare yeah and
that's the the whole thought you compare
yourself to somebody that's a thief of
Joy I I have a very simple philosophy
when it comes to comparison because I
use it more than I I get discouraged by
it sure so if it's if it's paralyzing
you then don't compare compare yourself
to you be a better version of you
tomorrow if it's not paralyzing you mhm
and it's pissing you off use it use it
so these other guys piss me off and I'm
like what the hell yeah why are this was
so obvious yeah that everybody should be
a media company anybody with have with
any chops should be a media company by
themselves and the opportunities will
present themselves in a myriad of ways
if you have the chops to do it and
you're not doing it 20 years people
going to look back and laugh at you like
I look back and laugh at my ear earlier
version of myself put throwing those
videos on vidler you know what I mean
that was dumb super dumb so equally dumb
is not being a media company today
sitting down talking with Patrick B
David had him on our P podcast he's
speaking at our event I mean he's going
after it he's building a campus to put
2,000 people on a campus just to make
content yeah he's bringing in big
podcasters underneath his umbrella he's
going after it big he's really WR he he
was willing to write Tucker Carlson $100
million check yeah uh
so that's smart and I'm like man I'm
thinking too small I I've got to change
my thinking yeah I guess in comparison
to if we were to compare oursel to a
professional athlete there might be a a
gap there that we can never cross but
Simon Sak talks about worthy Rivals
there might be rivals in business that
Inspire us challenge us and help us get
the grittiness back that's where it came
from the grittiness was by actually
getting better worthy Rivals well like I
said there's there's some consequences
to success sometimes uh it's what I call
success coma okay nobody can accuse you
of not working nobody can accuse you of
not being in the
game um but you're kind of you know
taking selfies and signing autographs
and kissing babies and going on Long
vacations and yeah you're not doing what
you did to get get you where you were
you know if you're if you're honest sure
and I've been through two or three or
four of them um you a big windfall and
he's like hm this is fun and you don't
double down you don't take that
opportunity so for
me I I needed
to have examples in front of me what did
he call it worthy what worthy Rivals
worthy Rivals yeah I don't view them as
Rivals but I I think I view them as
necessary examples MH of please show me
how to play Big Mr Beast show me how do
you get a 100 million views in 5 days
yeah uh you know what do you need to do
there Sean show me how I can get more
views and and grow my channel um Patrick
Show me how are you my team's taking two
days to turn around a podcast just on
color correction and edits and audio
quality and you're doing it live every
day um and it looks just fine it looks
great you know show me how you're
tightening this system up how you pick
the clips like when we did our podcast I
picked our our team picked some clips
and then his team picked some clips and
his Clips were a little bit better than
our Clips same content yeah I'm like
guys so show me I need to see it so
sometimes when I can see something to be
able to measure against um it's it's
inspiring for me it's motivating for me
uh and and recently like just this last
week you know Rob Deer dick yeah um have
you ever had him on no I'd love to
actually you you should he comes to
Vegas regularly yeah um he's a genius
kind of psycho too like in a good way he
is the most systemized person on Earth
yeah that's what I mean by the word I
don't know anybody quite like it but
when you see the result of it how much
balance he has how much time with his
family how much time on his health it's
how much time on his business yeah he
tracks it tracks the detail tracks
everything to the minute yeah he he
films
336 episodes of Ridiculousness yes per
year okay in a very short window of time
yes 4% of his time it's it's wild he
every year he got more efficient with it
it's also the basically the only show on
MTV Ridiculousness is 80% of MTV it's an
incredible case study unbelievable yeah
he he has a billion dollar deal over the
next seven years with that company right
so he you know when we first met he and
I eight years ago he's on his honeymoon
with his wife um
and my wife and I we we were all in Bora
bore we met now like a little jet ski
Excursion and his wife had read my book
so we made this connection we we connect
on the plane we become good friends and
at the time we're both worth about the
same amount he was his net worth is like
15 million my net worth is like 15
million yeah okay today his net worth is
like 400 sure while being completely
content happy balanced rested
fit um connected with his kids connected
with his wife because us entrepreneurs
we'll grind sometimes sure you know
we'll we'll just put put more on us
we'll just do more and more and more
we'll work 12 hours 14 hours 16 hours he
said no no no I'm going to be do better
with the time I'm going to be more
efficient with the time so that's my new
my new mission is to systemize
everything tighter whatever we could
have done in a day let's see if we can
do it in four hours if we can do it in
four hours let's see we can do it in two
what's a better system for every aspect
yeah so we so I kind of balance things
out because I'll I'll just I'll slave
away if I'm in The Grind Mode because I
kind of grind for a season then I
support for a season then I grind for a
season support for a season I my my new
mission is all about systems all about
systems systems are the secret now
should Network marketers use YouTube and
video 100% first of all uh Network
marketers can can use YouTube and should
I haven't used it as much as I should
I'm kind of waking my channel up we
talked what six months ago probably for
the first time um about that because I
was embarrassed it was kind of a Dumping
Ground for video and I was speaking so
much around the world and doing
different things I just wasn't it wasn't
really intentional it's just starting to
become intentional so first to build
your brand if you're an entrepreneur and
you're not building your brand you can
divide what your expected income should
be by by five maybe make 20% of what you
should be making if you build a big
brand you'll attract good talent you'll
you will attract opportunities you know
people go check you up nowadays it's
like what's your name let me go do a
little homework let me go watch a few
videos you don't have any videos all
right let me go look down LinkedIn see
if oh you got it over there all right
fine um are you in Instagram you know
what's that look like Facebook what's
that look like you're going to go check
this stuff out that's your calling card
nowadays is let me go check social see
if this person's for real yeah you know
if they're a real human being so one to
build your brand two to build your reach
three it's the easiest way in the world
to be able to organically start
conversations with everybody and all
businesses conversation yeah so what
YouTube will do is start a conversation
you keep the conversation going then you
can pivot it either into your product or
into some business or something more
meaningful yeah you know what I mean our
conversations we just kept the convers
ation going opportunities will present
themselves we'll do a lot of business
together over the years for sure I'm
completely aware of it um but it's not
wasn't necessarily the agenda the agenda
was bring value have conversations show
each other who we are what can we do how
can we go grow it so YouTube for sure
you're the expert at that pick a genre
pick a style pick something become known
for it you just don't be boring you know
that's the the ultimate uh rule I think
in all of the social stuff is don't be
boring and I'm learning I'm learning you
know I'm learning how to Anchor the the
promise in the first 5 seconds I'm
learning how to do because I'm a teacher
I don't really do that yeah you know
and there's so many things I'm doing to
not maximize but what I'll tell you if
you do enough quantity yes it won't
matter yes you'll find your voice you'll
find your hook you'll find your sense of
humor you'll find you know who's that
who's the YouTuber uh uh podcaster the
real softspoken girl who kind of mocks
celebrities Bobby Bobby something y
Bobby Brown no Bob Al Bobby alff yeah so
and she's just like you know you're kind
of ugly you know yeah kind of dead pan
sarcastic with that stupid beard you
know you're so old uh and just really
really quiet and and but it's a style
yeah so you can find whether it's hot
wings or that or whatever you can find
your own thing your own voice at the
beginning I was just copying Jim own
mostly yeah um you know when I first
started 35 years ago and then you find
your own your own Vibe but uh it
will it's
impossible for it not to give you a
multiplied return on the effort yes um
unless you completely ignore all the
opportunities that will present from it
you know what I mean absolutely so in
just a second I want you to answer the
question how can content creators maybe
someone's listening to this looking for
a business opportunity to monetize in a
different way than YouTube ad Revenue
than even affiliate marketing and some
of these other things and network
marketing could that be one of those
opportunities but before we get
there you've probably heard it said
network marketing is a
scam is that true no it's not but I
understand
the the uh
image and here's here here's where the
image comes
from Network marketers just can't help
but overhype everything they just can't
help it they they say it's you know you
don't have to sell anything and you know
this the easiest thing you'll ever do in
the world and and everybody's winning
and look at how much money this person
makes and look at their car and look at
all this stuff so it's promise promise
promise promise you know and all you got
to do is put in a little bit of money
and and it's just going to be a magic
beans dropped into the ground you know
go up to the sky and and you can retire
it's just amazing unbelievable and the
product it cures this and it does that
and it they overhype hype hype hype hype
like crazy and because of the hype it
can never live up to the that
expectation so people come in with that
expectation kind of going this sounds
too good to be true um but I'll give it
a try and the moment a person normally
joins network marketing they have like
three four five people in their head
that might join if they do it to and
it's kind of like a lotto ticket you
know there like a scratch off so they go
scratch those off and if one of those
five doesn't join then they rip it up
and they say you know what network
markeing doesn't work it's a scam here's
the truth it's virtually impossible for
you to lose money in network marketing
oh I lost money tell me how yeah it's
impossible how much does it cost to
start yeah it it depends on the company
but but a very small amount and you can
return that to the company and get your
money back so it's just
like it you you you cannot convince me
that you're going to lose money yeah can
you come in as an amateur lose
relationships if you're just handing out
business cards at funerals and you know
doing creepy stuff yeah you can do that
for sure um but if you're that's why we
called it GoPro the book GoPro if you're
going to do this be a professional yeah
you know like any professional skills be
classy but but here's what network
marketing does just so you understand um
and I would also say the scam piece of
it in every profession there's going to
be some people who do wrong mhm you know
there's the ftxs in the in the crypto
space yes that are that did it wrong
there's going to be the good people that
rise uh out of that you know all of that
attention and dominate the market inside
Network markting there's thousands of
companies are there some that are at
straight up scams yep will they get
exposed pretty quickly yep and the good
ones will you know continue to grow and
build and grow and build but just for a
basic tutorial there's only four things
that people do in network marketing they
sell a product using Word of Mouth
advertising right which is they educate
consumers two they recruit they build a
team so they start get some leverage
it's not just all on them y three they
duplicate they teach people how to
recruit and sell start building an
organization Y and four they lead they
improve the productivity of the teams
that they have based upon the leadership
so that's what I do is I teach people
how to do those things and grow in scale
right not for everybody for sure but
here's what I would tell you I would
challenge anyone in the world including
an influencer including YouTubers you
know for the average person starting
today network marketing is not perfect
it's for sure the catch really is you
have to endure the loss of social esteem
from ignorant people people who don't
really understand it or maybe prejudged
it so you have to endure that it's not
fun sometimes but it's not perfect but I
will tell you I would take the Pepsi
Challenge on any entrepreneurial
Endeavor uh network marketing model
versus any other side hustle model and
network marketing is better for sure I'd
rather do network marketing than Uber
I'd rather do network marketing then
what any solopreneur Adventure because
you don't get scale I work for myself
I'm a graphic designer all right fine
stop designing some graphics and tell me
how much money you're going to make if
you stop working it stops but if you do
network marketing right you grow a
network you grow a network you know
Robert kosaki said that uh wealthy
people look for and build Networks
everybody else just looks for work you
know so you can build a network on
social but how are you monetizing if
you're just going to be doing your your
ad
Revenue yeah you got to get pretty big
and pretty influential for that to be a
meaningful number but could you build a
tribe of super rabid people and then say
you know hey you know how I pay for
doing all this passion stuff you know I
I I knit you know mittens and that's my
thing you know I I bake cupcakes and and
my channel is The Cupcake of the day um
but you know how I I afford to do this I
got this other thing over here that
makes me some money yep if you you know
DM me if you want to find out about it
I'll show you and you can even work with
me if you want to so I I've known people
who've recruited like 10 12 thousand
people uh from their social media
platforms yes and then those people
start start growing an organization they
create huge huge income so instead of an
ad automatically being inserted into
your podcast then maybe it's your own
that you say you know hey you need to
make some extra money you know you've
got ad Mission you're hungry you're
coachable go go check this out might
might not be for you but check it out if
you like it then we we can do something
if you don't then you don't have to but
I just think if you're going to do
something in addition to what you're
doing you have to have scale yeah you
have to have leverage and if you don't
have leverage it's just another job and
you're going to be more and more unhappy
having 15 jobs it's fascinating because
in the list of ways to make money on
YouTube people are excited about the
crater economy and this is I think an
under overlooked and underrated
opportunity because they want YouTube to
pay them ad Revenue that's fine
affiliate marketing cool but not scale
and sometimes the percentages can be low
you could do brand deals but those are
also dry up that's not that's not
automation that is a job because you're
going to work for each brand on a
repeated scale you could try to make
your own coffee cups or merch or
t-shirts why not if you build a big
enough brand and people want that you
can try to get crowdfunding patreon uh
Channel memberships also cool package a
course big fan um do an online course of
some kind do coaching or events but you
have this whole other opportunity of
network marketing that could be a part
of your YouTube channel brand if your
channel brand was helping people get
healthier if it was
anti-aging um if it was cooking Health
biohacking you could look for a company
and find products that you believe in
and love that could tie into your
channel your whole channel would not
have to be taken over by that but it
could be one of the verticals with which
a product you already love and use is
integrated into your content but then
you would have created the ability for
not just actually essentially having
your own product because network
marketing is giving you a business right
um that you don't have to do all the
heavy lifting and the distribution and
all the shipping and then addition to
that if you start recruiting people as
you mentioned and people with social
followings have that Advantage then it
is this massive again I think underrated
and overlooked opportunity also because
I often encourage people the size like
the Thousand true fans thing everyone's
trying to get a million subscribers
because they hope you
off of a volume of that big will pay
them ad Revenue not realizing that if
you have a better vehicle a better money
plan then even with a smaller audience
this could become a full-time thing and
network marketing could be a way to do
that let let me can I ask you a question
please somebody's got a million
followers on YouTube what would be a
successful metric as far as number of
video views per month on average you
know a a reasonable not not a not a
rockstar but reason yeah well these days
how many views a month getting 10% can
be hard 10% of the of the subscribers so
so a million aill a million I just was
studying these videos and comparing
things and I looked at a Channel with 4
million subscribers and 400,000 views on
the video was pretty impressive I'm I'm
talking about video views for the month
total for the
month um shorts make it a little messy
um but cuz you know we're we're 2.5
we're getting about 8 million views a
month on think media 2.5 million
subscribers so so let's let's say take
that down to a million that would be
about 5 million views yeah something
like that and would you consider
yourself above average yes okay um so
let's let's take it down to 3 million
views sure how much is somebody going to
make from 3 million views 3 million
views assuming Reon $1 RPM is a $3,000
and we have higher RPM of $7 so we we'd
make you know 20 grand so anyone would
make somewhere from three to $15,000
probably anywhere from 3 to 20 and it
really depends on the niche yeah yeah
SO3 to $15,000 per month from the ad
revenue from the ad Revenue that so
under monetizes that Community it's
unbelievable yes it's just pitiful I
mean if I can give you some brag stats
I've helped almost a thousand people
make a million dollars a year yeah that
are not branded that are not influencers
not famous they're just average people
who are ambitious in the network
marketing space I've helped tens of
thousands make six figures I've helped
millions make a nice part-time income
which is what a YouTube channel is for
most people Millions yeah so now take
that following and three million views
and now you can guide a little trickle
of them over into some sustainable
vehicle that will continue to replicate
and repeat with or without your
involvement
you know that those ambitious people
will go take it from there MH you're if
you get 3 million views and you don't
find out find a way to personally enroll
300 of them total yeah that's you know
how much money you can make from 300
people coming into into your team in one
month sure and any kind of compound it's
it's Mammoth people
are if if you do it right whatever
you're earning from your ad Revenue
should be a minimum 10 times if you can
take a small portion of those people
siphon them over to the side have them
check out what you do in order to be
able to monetize your business and let
them go let them go do it and let the
company take care of all the support you
know find a a genre or or a product
category a service category that matches
your content that's my next question so
going along the lines of realizing of
course there's Bad actors in any indust
or there's some there's companies that
aren't great but there's also companies
that are amazing I know as a side note
whenever I drive through Utah there's
like there's like a corridor of the
different warehouses and all the
companies and so what would be for those
looking to earn extra income what would
be the first steps they should take to
get into the network marketing world
world right you said find a company
product or a service that aligns with
what you're already doing how would you
encourage somebody to do the research to
find that alignment and and we're a
mission driven Community here so of
course we're looking about how to
monetize but we want it to be Service
First of course the worst thing ever
would be to get a buy a product we
didn't believe in so how do I do my
research to find a product or a service
or something that man well that I can
legitimately try out maybe I have to
test a few how would I go about that
well first of all if if you give me u a
a category of content creator Ben benz's
helping people with uh uh Health keto
Camp he's helping people with ketosis uh
so and we can spin off a lot of health
health there's a there's hundreds of
Health companies there's companies
specifically on keto there's companies
on Wellness there's company on on brain
Wellness uh gut health there's all you
have to do is just type it type that
into a Google Search and you'll you'll
be able to pull those up and take a look
let me give you five quick criteria to
take a look at when trying to pick a
company perfect one take a look at the
product and you need to answer four
questions number one is there a need for
this product number two does a product
meet that need number three is it priced
to sell is it competitive and number
four is it priced for profit is there
enough margin for to be worth your time
and then I would say fifth does it align
with your community okay if you if you
say yes to that then then take a look at
the company do they have the financial
capability and the lead ERS ship
necessary to be able to Pivot through
difficult times do they have any kind of
track record any kind of experience
anything any evidence that you can point
to of success uh to lower your risk feel
comfortable I'm not saying startup
doesn't have benefits but it's a myth
that don't people at the beginning make
all the money they're normally people
they get the arrows in the back um and
it's a myth that the only the people at
the top make money that's not true
either so take a look at the company
itself if you're comfortable that they
they've got enough leadership to pivot
if if they make mistakes third take a
look at the compensation structure how
can you make money on a direct sale you
know like an affiliate type thing and
then how can you make money from team
building and if you can make money you
know kind of startup midterm big money
you feel comfortable that that's good
fourth thing to take a look at what's
the support that they provide you know
what can you do on your side what will
they do on their side what's available
to kind of Leverage your time and then
fifth take a look at the timing is this
the right time for this product or this
product
category um is is it is it it doesn't
have to like be white hot all the time
it just has to be useful um and if it
matches your community you answer answer
you don't have to have all five to have
a good business but if you have all five
then I think you say yes and at least
explore it because your risk is so low
you can literally take I'm only going to
take have 10 people and go test this out
and tell us you tell me if it's any good
if it's it's no good find another one
you know so yeah that's how i' would
approach it there's not just Health
Products there's not just different
types of products but I don't know if
it's a new trend but one of the things
I've noticed is there's network
marketing real estate companies yeah big
big huge and insurance and insurance
okay my question for you if you were an
agent full-time you're a real estate
agent if you were selling
insurance would you pivot switch leave
your current maybe traditional model or
some kind of a different model to be in
one of those opportunities and why in 5
seconds you know because the traditional
model is this you become an agent you
become a broker who has a group of
agents and when that other person
becomes a broker you lose those people
right and then they go build their thing
and you're always kind of dealing with
your little group of Agents but there's
limits you you're not going to get
compensated on you know generations of
house sales or real estate or wealth
management uh
vehicles but if I if I could build a
team of Agents yeah I can go recruit a
bunch of Agents give them a very very
high commission margin that that kind of
crushes the the regular uh real estate
model competition when it comes to their
fees and there's a residual impact so
I'm I you know the the the dream for a
real estate agent is 5 years from now
you're not putting out an open house
sign and you know serving cheese and
crackers on a Sunday afternoon when you
could be doing something else you you
got people building I mean I know a guy
who's making 2 million doll a month in
one of these real estate companies yeah
just on building a team and teaching
them how to be more productive and
they're all sharing ideas they're all
growing together and I know one
insurance company has 150 people making
a million dollars a year wow 150 people
network marketing uh model uh making a
million dollar a year that's
unbelievable I think for sure I've heard
I heard one person say too that for
sometimes the smoke and shade that
network marketing gets there's a whole
other perspective that it has one been
historically one of the greatest ways to
develop leaders to reprogram your mind y
to change your thinking to teach you new
skills and like you said it's you you
didn't lose that much money even if you
ended up being lazy you didn't follow
through if you took away some
relationships and some skills it's the
most valuable thing in the world you
became more valuable the flip side
though I think also when it's funny
critics of of this those real estate
companies or those insurance companies
are presenting a better opportunity I
think that's one of the under one of the
questions I ask as a CEO I don't feel
entitled that my team members will stay
with me I am asking how can I provide
them a better opportunity how can I not
just honor their skills and work culture
and work life balance or whatever else
but we're going to do we're going to do
it wrong and I'm not going to to keep
people long term if I don't share the
wealth if I don't create opportunities
for residual incomes or increasing
incomes and that's why we're doing
profit share and asking oursel all these
different questions if anything learning
that skill set small business owners
entrepreneurs people that are looking
for an opportunity people that are
creating opportunities for others
there's a lot to learn here one of the
things patri B David has been helping me
with he's really great at comp plans he
thinks in comp plans he thinks in in
terms of his own team and whatnot and
and of course he did that very good at
PHP but now just even with his current
staff and it sounds like and do people
know that he that his company is a
network marketing company I maybe they
did I I probably publicly that they
wouldn't have made that connection until
you articulated it yeah it it and built
that huge business sold an interest in
that business still runs that business
and is also kind of growing as media
Empire now yes super fascinating and and
what you're saying is right there's a
better way to to uh um to compensate a
person yes who shows ambition the whole
world's going to per performance-based
model every single job is going to be
switched to Performance Based not by the
hour not by the the the month not by the
year government's going to be the last
one to switch to that but every place
else is going to be we're going to pay
you for the result yes give us the
result you get the money give us the
next result you get the money you can't
hide in companies anymore that those
days are are rapidly disappearing so if
you're going to live in a
performance-based economy anyway why
limit with a why why live with a cap see
in the side of the network marketing
model the interesting thing is if
somebody's making $2 million a
month okay as an independent contractor
connected to a company in a traditional
company not a network marketing company
a traditional company how long would
they let them make that two million a
month they'd have meetings real fast
yeah they they would like is he really
worth sure 2 million a month I bet he'd
still do it for a million a month yeah I
bet he' do it for half a million let's
cut his territory let's cut his
commission let's revamp the whole
structure let's carve out another
Division and move it to somebody else
underneath somebody else you know this
is too much you know I like I said I've
helped a thousand people make a million
dollars a year in network
marketing none of them would be able to
survive a board of directors meeting in
a traditional company justifying that
income but what they traded was being
underpaid for period of time fairly paid
for a short period of time and now they
get overpaid and that's the promise of
what they do inside of there they'll
give you Awards they won't try and cut
your legs out and change the comp plan
and change your territory or whatever so
it's so much for a high achiever it's so
much better uh if if you're going to be
performance compensated anyway yes it's
so much better so like I say it's not
for everybody you have to have some
thick skin because there's a lot of
misunderstanding from the amateurs
running around promising the world but
uh if you can get past that and see the
real numbers whatever the profession is
or whatever the product is there's
products physical products there's
technology products there's educational
platforms there's insurances and uh real
estate and you're going to see other
other aspects of the economy
compensating people in this way
creatively it's fascinating before we
hit our final topic I found some stats
for the UK that suggest that women are
typically more involved in network
marketing than men and in Europe 85%
versus 15% with the largest percentage
in favor of women out of pure
curiosity why are women more involved in
network marketing than men globally it's
like I think if you take the whole world
it's like
73% it might be 77 somewhere in the 70s
okay 70 70 plus per. seven women for
every three men Word of Mouth
advertising I mean women talk they have
friends
somebody loses weight they're going to
say well what did you do and they're
going to tell their friends they you
know they got this essential oil you
know or they got this special filtered
water or they've got this or they've got
that they've got a solution to
somebody's problems and and they're very
good at educating the consumer and
they're very good at word of- mouth
advertising um and they're very good at
team building you know building a
culture building you know growing
through all that that guys are too don't
get me wrong and for for most of my I've
been doing this 35 years the early
stages all all the top earners were guys
M and and but the the the ladies were
selling and the top earners were the
guys it was weird but now it's a
complete shift and I would say it's you
know PE the the people on stage speaking
you know the big uh earners it's like
5050 something like that I I would say a
lot of the sellers you know the home
party people the direct selling
folks um a lot more women on that side
the builders I'd say probably 5050 I'm
curious what's your thoughts I like how
you said you know it's not for everybody
but it's if you're ambitious you want to
take your destiny in your own hands your
future in your own hands if you're
willing to put in the work if you have
thick skin and you want scale and you
want scale and you're willing to learn
you're willing to grow Yahoo finance
revealed this stat 7 million American
men are done looking for work and
they've punched out why the LA the US
Labor Market remains incredibly tight
with the economy adding 517,000 jobs
around 7 million Prime AG men between
the ages of 25 and 54 are sitting out
they're just not working they're just
going I'm not going to work I'm just
going to not work I'm just going to be
lazy what's your opinion and why that's
happening and and what problem that has
for America where's that start where
does where's that coming from from
there's stats in our in our country that
I completely don't understand like one
statistic is the average household
income in this country is $55,000 a year
MH I want you to just imagine for a
moment that you have $55,000 before
taxes MH and you have to take care of
your
family I don't know how it's even
possible how how do you have insurance
how do you how do you how do you survive
I I don't even get it for that so that's
one the other thing is we've been
trained to be this Army of
robots doing as we're
told you know the educational system is
like an employee
Farm we grow employees in the
educational system that'll fit into
somebody else's entrepreneurial dream
you know oh we have a a crop of
accountants over here let's spread them
out to these different companies we have
a crop of attorneys and we're going to
spread them out over here we have a crop
of whatever salesp people we're going to
spread them out over here right so at
some point a person Rebels against being
told what to do and and not enjoying it
working with people that they don't like
being underappreciated underpaid for
their value and that's the trade that
people make they think they're getting
security but they trade this illusion of
security for a regular every two week
paycheck and they they become
disillusioned and they say you know what
I'm out of this game I'm I I'm tired of
working for this boss that has to die
for me to get a promotion I'm tired of
somebody chopping my legs out from under
me in a political environment in my
company I'm tired of being discriminated
against because of my gender or my age
or or you know my race or my beliefs I'm
tired of it I'm out I'm done I'm not
doing this anymore but but they're
checking out of of a system that didn't
serve them it might have served our
parents or our grandparents generation
you know that get a job work for them
for 40 years get retired all that stuff
that's not our world today people are
pivoting every three to five years to
something m
but I'll answer your question uh in this
way why am I still
working when I have all my needs taken
care of I have my dream lifestyle y I
have all the stuff why two reasons two
things make me happy one is when I'm
growing and two is when I'm contributing
and both have to be in place because if
I'm growing and I'm not contributing I
just get over bloated and I'm just
restless and unhappy if I'm contributing
giving giving giving but I'm not growing
then I'm emptied out so I have to have
this Loop of constantly growing and
contributing growing and contributing
and the the there was great fuel for me
to get my needs taken care of and my
family that was a drive but most people
get to that spot and once they're there
they go hm this isn't what I thought you
know it's so cliche you know they the
person makes the money and they're
they're unhappy they're unhappy because
they don't have a a mission a cause a a
passion a purpose they did it to try and
get away from
it so they get the money they go to the
beach how many pen coladas can you have
before you you know if you're an
entrepreneur you're going to be
re-engineering that beach real fast and
and see how many businesses you can
create off of that beach because you
know take me to a Sandy Beach and put me
on a on a lawn chair and I'm good for
about an hour maybe two but you you tell
me I have to stay there two weeks I'm
gonna lose my mind yeah right so growth
and contribution is one thing and being
in the
game you know it's so fun to be in the
game when you check out of the game you
kind of check out of life I think and
I'm not saying check out of just work
but I mean just check out say I'm done
I'm done I'm I'm checked out of this
this life well tell me what example you
shown to your kids tell me how happy you
are really tell me how much Netflix you
can watch before you've seen it all
tell me you know how many beers you
going to drink out on the patio before
he's like I I I need a project yeah and
some some people throw themselves into
golf or they throw themselves into this
hobby or that hobby but what I love
about what I do is the fuel to take care
of myself was one thing but the fuel
when I get to help
others is a super fuel I live for the
tap on the shoulder all right so as we
land the plane um I saw an article on
entrepreneur about Tom Hanks talking
about an advertisement that was using
his likeness that he never approved and
so it was fake AI someone was able to
turn him into an avatar duplicate his
voice duplicate his likeness and start
selling something I'm curious how are
you embracing AI do you think AI is a
net positive or negative for society and
as we even started this whole
conversation talking about some of the
crisis ahead
how disruptive do you think AI is going
to be to the next 12 to 24 months our
ability to adapt to Pivot to this is an
opportunity I can get in front of this I
can be the first one that talks about
this I can move this over here how can I
use this to do that you know we built a
$20 million studio just down the street
from here yeah to adapt during covid to
do hybrid events right full 360 it's
like you're in a Coliseum it's
unbelievable uh 25,000 foot space to
host hybrid events in person now 400
people in person and the the most we
ever had um it's like
350,000 or something like that live
interactive uh so that's an example of
taking a technology and saying how can
we use it with creativity so when we're
a hologram walking around somewhere when
uh AI is is I I just had a meeting this
morning with my team because we really
want to be able to serve the different
languages around the world with the
content cuz we have you know there's 120
million people involved in the network
marketing space and a lot of them don't
speak English so there's a technology
that we're vetting right now that will
take my voice and my content and will
translate it in my voice in Japanese in
Spanish in Portuguese in German whatever
you with the full dialect the whole
thing and create a great experience for
those people so it's going to be my
voice doing it even though don't know
those languages I think that's
tremendous in in order to be able to
open up opportunities to help more
people so it's just like whatever
happens it's like are we going to be
able to stop AI it's been happening for
10 years it's still still going it's not
going to go anywhere y we're not going
to be able to stop it so what are we
going to do about it you know if we
can't control how it's regulated all
right how can we use it to our advantage
how can we make sure you know can we
hope that it doesn't get used for evil
too much uh I think with the the me too
movement and everybody being canceled
and stuff there's going to be a lot of
hold on let's find out if that was for
real uh what that was said or done
because it might have just been a deep a
deep fake hopefully that'll give
everybody a little pause before they get
too hard on judgment but we're living in
an exciting time yes uh and if you're an
entrepreneur it doesn't matter what
comes out you'll just pivot yeah if
you're not literally entire departments
and entire companies are going to be
wiped out overnight faster than you ever
saw they they estimate that 60% of the
S&P 500 will no longer exist in 5 years
geez gone so gobbled up wiped out
technology made obsolete we don't know
but if you're an entrepreneur in any of
those
companies all you got to do is find
what's the next thing get in front of it
I remember talking to Gary vaynerchuk I
like you're going to talk about wine and
all this stuff when are you going to you
need to build something you know what do
you got build something you know tasting
wine and helping the wine libraries one
it's great but you're you're so talented
yeah you know go build and and he built
this monster agency and and you know
he's innovating you seeing innovate
inside of the the web 3 Tom Bill U
another example of lot spend a lot of
money in innovating inside of web 3 the
entrepreneur will always see it they'll
always get a little bit in front of it
they'll little be ahead of the wave
they'll take advantage of momentum and
everybody else will have plenty to blame
sure in the meantime well I mean it's a
good way to wrap the conversation kind
of where we started as well if you've
listened to this entire episode you've
got to reprogram your mind you have to
embrace the entrepreneur mentality you
have to adapt or die you have to
innovate um and the good news is it'll
be The Tale of Two Cities because if you
continue to develop new skills learn
level up grow if you Embrace change then
you can thrive in these coming years and
so you've added so much value so
grateful for you and uh with 35 years in
the industry all the wisdom I know our
community is so grateful that you took
the time to come all the way over from
across Vegas to uh the think media
studios here for people that want to
connect with you shout out where are the
best places of course we'll link it all
up in the show notes find me on social
you know Eric worry or network marketing
Pro either way um I I didn't come here
with any agenda I've got nothing to sell
uh I what I would say is for this
community if you're listening to this
free content and you're maybe watching
the free videos that think media and
Sean puts out shorten the learning curve
and go by the course get the coaching
get the mentoring rip the Band-Aid off
get better get better fast time is so
important if you if you can get where
you need to go in 3 months instead of 3
years and then compound that for the
rest of your working
life it's it's it's not even comparable
it's not 10 times it's 100 times it's a
thousand time time is so valuable and
the best cheat Co you can have is a
coach a mentor virtual mentors are
better than physical mentors and
masterminds you know that that's the
best way get in proximity with greatness
pay for the
privilege and use that in order to get
better faster uh that's the most
important thing time really matters Eric
wary appreciate you